video has emerged of a brazen ms-13
murder happened in broad daylight on New
York City's subway yesterday the video
shows a group of men brawling on a
crowded platform and then one of them
repeatedly opens fire we warn you as you
watch the video is awful the alleged
shooter is in custody tonight police say
he's a 26-year old
ms-13 member with previous arrests and
that the murder you just saw was related
to gang violence underway in the area
that's what the police say talking heads
on TV say the whole thing is fake none
of this is happening and you're a racist
if you think otherwise we may have
noticed where we're going a kind of
religious revival here in Washington not
the old-fashioned tented kind of revival
with altar calls and spiritual
Redemption this is the modern version
where climate policy takes the place of
the Eucharist and a member of Congress
from San Francisco where's the Pope at
yet it's no less fervent watch our
cities head theologian Nancy Pelosi
issue her final decree on the ethics of
border walls it is Swift and final y'all
is an immorality it's not who we are as
a nation the wall is an immorality
between countries the wall in my view is
an immorality immoral that's the final
word from the high Church of progressive
liberalism do they know about this in
the Holy Land though apparently they
don't because just yesterday Israel
America's closest ally in that region
started construction on a massive new
wall a border wall it's 20 feet high
it'll be made of galvanized steel it's
gonna be built directly on top of an
existing underground wall officials in
Israel say the new wall will connect to
another wall that extends right into the
Mediterranean that means the wall will
prevent migration from the sea as well
once all this is done the Gaza Strip
will be entirely surrounded by walls is
really expects to finish this by the end
of the year Israel already has a similar
barrier on his border with Egypt that
wall cut the No
of illegal African migrants from almost
15,000 in 2010 to a total of just 14 six
years later that's some wall has anyone
told Archbishop Pelosi about any of this
well she denounced Israel as immoral
some want to ask her that question and
keep asking her until she answers it
well that mean you've been telling us
about all kinds of Russia conspiracies
for over two years now it's a pretty
simple model you take a person or a
group who you don't like who are saying
things you disagree with and then you
build a narrative that ties them to
Russia latest example comes as previous
examples have come from NBC News NBC
News is smearing anti-war Democratic
presidential candidate Tulsi Gabbard as
a Kremlin favorite NBC based the story
on so-called experts a group recently
caught fabricating Russia stories at the
behest of the Democratic Party